his ID had been linked to a number of
other crimes and within a few minutes of
the phone call he was
I'm just paralyzed with fear Zach
welcome back hey Brad so this week's
story is hits really close to home for
you tell me a little bit about where you
found it what happened yeah so last
Monday my dad got a call from someone
claiming to be a federal agent they said
that his Social Security card had been
linked to an abandoned car that was
found somewhere near the border of Texas
there were 22 pounds of cocaine in the
car blood and his ID had been linked to
a number of other crimes and within a
few minutes of the phone call he was I'm
just paralyzed with fear and at that
point like any kind of rational thought
goes out the window and he was on the
phone with this person for a number of
hours and in the end ended up getting
scammed for around three thousand
dollars in gift cards from Target so uh
all of last week I was on the phone with
the FTC target corporate other
government agencies and local
authorities just trying to piece
together how these scams work and
getting it a little bit into the
psychology of why we fall for them - so
your dad is like an intelligent guy
spent many years as a teacher has its
wits about him obviously his faculties
about him and what do you think made him
fall victim in this case it's a great
question I mean you know the FTC told me
yesterday that in 2019 there were there
was something like a hundred and seventy
million dollars worth of the
scams 400,000 Americans fell for these
so-called imposter scams over the phone
last year and I think what they do is
you know they start the call very
authoritative Lee these are these are
not amateur scammers they're you know
they're very skilled con men and they
use tiny little details like they'll
give you the badge number the exact
badge numbers that are based on you know
what badge numbers would actually look
like in certain government agencies they
even gave them like a callback number
that was it was mirrored to look like a
legitimate government phone number so
they throw in all these little details
throughout the call to really convince
you that you're the target of a
government-led investigation and then
you get to this weird point where you're
walking into a target buying gift cards
which to any outsider like you or me
who's not a part of the scam it's just
like at that point what are you doing
you know it's no one buys no government
official asks you to buy gift cards but
at that point you're so paralyzed with
fear and some kind of hypnosis on us
that you just can't really pull yourself
to reason so this is a really sad tale
about what happened to your dad I'm
really sorry to hear this this stories
in the hands of a great storyteller I
look forward to seeing what you do with
it
hopefully it'll do a lot of people some
good so make sure you guys open the
story on Sunday thanks for joining the
sack
[Music]